this fourth of July when you watch the
fireworks do you think about this the
Declaration of Independence we should
after all the holidays meant to honor
this not just fireworks oh those are
nice although it's ironic that since
America's founding government has grown
so much that you may not be allowed to
buy fireworks where you live all these
places ban them in the name of safety
the declaration isn't about safety or
things government should do it's about
limiting government it's about freedom
the founders were sick of British
oppression they worried about government
having too much power Thomas Jefferson
and his colleagues wrote the Declaration
to create a new form of government one
where people could rule themselves it
worked when the declaration was signed
America was considered a backwater but
very few years later America was the
most prosperous and probably the freest
country in the world the fourth of July
celebrates the Declaration which led to
the Constitution the document that
really lays out the rules meant to limit
government trust no man with too much
powers at Jefferson bind them with the
chains of the Constitution its chains
have done a lot of good we have a right
not to have our homes searched without a
warrant a right to bear arms to free
speech it's good we declared
independence from Britain because in
Britain government sentenced this man to
more than a year in jail of course the
preacher faced a man arrested for making
this Facebook live video outside a
courthouse others get locked up for
things they write hundreds get arrested
every year sentence for writing an
offending comment fortunately in America
thanks to the Constitution we can say
most anything we want without be jail we
also have a right to bear arms but the
country we rebelled against has some of
the strictest gun regulations in the
world those regulations haven't stopped
crime sheppy and March were the
first-ever months that London had more
suspected murders than New York so now
they're going after people who have
knives one British police agency bragged
about a weapon sweep that found scissors
and pliers but don't worry they've been
taken off the streets I'm glad I live in
America where I can carry pliers and
speak freely and there's more to the
Constitution than the first and second
amendments Supreme Court overrule the
Supreme Court overruled stream Court
overruled is the Constitution divided
government power in ways that limit
authoritarian politicians from both
parties we are throwing them the hell
out of our country Trump's own appointee
ruled that a law making it easier to
deport some immigrants was too vague
allow intelligence agencies to track who
a terrorist is in contact with the
Supreme Court stopped the Obama
administration a hundred times no
President Obama the Fourth Amendment
says government cannot just search
people's cell phones they have to get a
search warrant no you can't just declare
carbon-dioxide to be a pollutant a major
setback tonight for President Obama's
climate change initiative I'm glad we
have this document it is often kept
presidents and Congress and judges from
grabbing too much power the limits
stated in here have not fully succeeded
unfortunately Thomas Jefferson promised
a wise and frugal government frugal give
me a break we're already more than 21
trillion dollars in debt Jefferson also
wrote about leaving men free to regulate
their own pursuits now we've got more
than 180,000 pages of rules still the
Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence have helped keep us free
that's something to celebrate
[Music]